hey guys Greg here hey guys we need him
here
I need a star from they need a stargazer
Channel she was hanging out after we had
dinner smoke some weed sorts of coke
shots and heroin
now all off of this this represent
hahahahaha
back and forth past midnight right now
the ghost in the shell' trailer number
to draw crazy I was like man I still
have to watch my copy of ghost in the
shell and then I found out she has seen
it's been a very long time yes but I one
of my favorites actually I was like well
then you got to watch this trailer when
I ended you're here yes I've been
waiting for this trailer I found out she
hasn't seen any of the trailers for it
no cheezer's everywhere I'm not one I
didn't know they were already out I
didn't get you at Gregory I think the
visual is about to blow your and a ball
low with a cocaine right
[Music]
Wow watching you you have to remember
[Music]
the known terrorist and he killed again
hey I didn't just kill them Hackett's
away whoa everywhere an or I will find
him boom Shakalaka
[Music]
never talk about your parent fragment
there was an attack you were dying we
saved you and how do you save others
everything they told you would lie you
add a family remember that you are
[Music]
they save you my stolen while vigil
betrayed
[Music]
she's hooked had a cream bring head
if you determine
thank you
[Music]
they created me but they cannot control
me
yeah we'll look at her cross when she's
worried that he'll good I mean is the
outfit man I'm not a pervert moves I
don't have to be standing there like a
man would make you feel I was looking
and she was a can't help but try to
figure it out yeah so visually that
looks amazing yeah it looks like anime
do you know it does have well not really
but it does look like well because the
anime was so long ago but it does look
yeah it looks like it's falling you know
it's funny because there's a lot of you
matrix matrix right I guess there's a
lot of matrix
esque yeah like things going on and that
trailer which is funny because I don't
know if you know this but the witch
which I'll do that goes from the shell
isn't inspirator there you go and so
it's like it's nice to see it come full
circle yeah we're now they look like
they're being US inspired kind of by the
matrix because yeah they're with the
hackey the other mind well that's that's
straight dial I thought I'm lightning is
a tray of the major someone like no
that's actually I'm actually I'm
animating so yeah I'm digging it man it
looks like it's visually beautiful like
the everything looks great
Karla Jim Hanson is hot and I know she's
got a lot of like flak because of this
you know not being white because she's
yeah not Asian but I feel like she's
going to do a good job just from that
clip that I saw and that's really
important when you have these like
people that are taking these characters
that you've grown to love and anime you
really need to see those characters come
to life as you imagine them as you saw
them in the enemy so you in the anime
you really like her character I did
because that's my one concern I like I
haven't seen the anime so I don't really
watch it I I own it you own inherent one
yeah we're watching [ __ ] yeah I need a
refresh or two especially since the
movies coming out I would love to watch
it again
I'm planning on what I want to watch a
little closer to the release of the
movie something and doing like a
comparison right yeah okay I can see how
I mean I feel like it'll really sit with
you though though my concerns when I say
them from all the footage I've seen from
these trailers and like
visually looks cool and I love all the
designs of cinematography looks
excellent like everything about it was
super cool yeah I'm just a little
concerned like none of the trailers that
may be truly intriguing to who Scarlett
Johansson is the character yeah it's
like okay she's a machine yeah I guess
she wasn't a machine formerly actually
human turned robot but I'm still like
I'm not that drawn to her character
still in this trim like it seems like
she's going to be a rather
two-dimensional performer I think so
would trailers like this it's hard to
really get that across it is but the
thing is a lot of her character in the
anime she is a little bit like brooding
you know and a little bit stoic yeah I
mean scene yeah I think her I'm
definitely gonna watch it I mean I don't
care about yeah I'm watching it it's
like it looks awesome it's gonna bring
back some memories okay let me ask you
this for someone who has seen the
original do you feel like they gave away
the whole movie in the trailer could the
trailer I feel like showed you a while
it does but no definitely not what it's
very much more involved than what just
showed okay sure makes me feel like
first act a lot of it's good to be
world-building then okay hinting at
there's some bigger threat going on
Lisa's this robot maker thingy person
has given her her past halfway here's a
film and then you know she's like oh
she's conflicting a little bit between
who to fight for the news I have to go
after them because they are bad in the
end yeah well I feel like a lot of
animes are kind of they run that same
road but it's very engaging and in the
way they play it out is going to be I
feel like hopefully they'll do a good
job with playing it out because that's
really important hopefully they don't
divert too much from the original anime
because that's something that I actually
really cannot stand about okay these
live-action movies when they're taking
from the enemies because it's like you
know you know the characters so well you
know the story so well and then they go
and [ __ ] [ __ ] up and change things that
just gets under my skin it's like no
this is not what this character's like
this is not what's supposed to happen
and that that I think if they stay true
to the anime then it'll be okay alright
well it has my money already yeah thank
you
alright guys what do you think of it I
know a lot of you are
we already hate this movie it could be
good an adaptation of a human today it
happened it happened you got to get over
it it's there with a show let's give it
a shot you would not like that it
absolutely good new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects cried
for the real 18 XR I need a stargazer go
check her out and shout out to Scarlett
Johansson or second body o kansan gosh
yeah or bum you know you are never not
be beautiful that is never gonna be a
thing ever gonna be a thing ever
I'm trying not to make a camel so common
she doesn't have one yeah I didn't see
one I mean I was mainly staring at food
go back after amazing tonight I mean the
cookies there's no yeah there's not a
lot of camel toe going on man
all right there's no nipple eat it's
like a Barbie doll yeah literally
Scarlett Johansson as a Barbie doll so
yeah not too bad though looking good man
yeah you want to the camera now I mean I
think we need to it's a thing